liberals are once again blaming kovid
for a crime surge shocker progressive
d.a say the spike in crime is because of
the pandemic and the media of course is
eating it up but what about defunding
the police no cash bail and other soft
on crime policies keep in mind the fbi
just released new numbers that show
murders soared nearly 30 percent in 2020
john
blamen coveted i mean isn't this fairly
obvious you let bad guys out of prison
they do bad stuff like that kind of
happens once in a while pretty sure
that's how bad guys look at it yeah that
uh you know if you don't have to post
bail
and you can steal up to this amount and
nobody's going to say anything about it
yeah that's pretty much a bad guy's
dream
right there is to have a situation like
that but the question is why on earth
would you want your town to be like that
like the people in charge that are
making these decisions why are they
putting us in that position yeah and uh
the only thing i could think of is you
know you called it it's mainly liberal
cities out there
what's their thought process they want
destruction they want chaos they want
these things why so they can have more
control over their town maybe the wilder
it gets the more they can clamp down
that's the only reasoning i can i can
find behind it because if you ran your
household like that as a dad if i just
told my two kids okay now you can do
whatever you want nobody's in trouble i
wouldn't have a house waiting for me in
nashville when i came back home that's
not the way humans react there has to be
consequences if you're going to commit
crime and all the regular people live in
these towns they're trying to escape
yeah dana i don't want to put you on the
spot cause you but you're the most sober
analyst you know
you are like you like really not drunk
you're very level-headed no yeah nothing
to do with intoxicants but
i mean they know what works right i mean
the broken windows policing the giuliani
era and then you dump it and crime goes
up i mean it really does beg the
question like is this deliberate or is
this just a pure political play for
votes and who's voting for this this
morning when i was getting ready for a
newsroom i saw this story
saying oh actually the crime is up
because of covid not because of policies
that have led to it and i said we should
do this on the five because for a long
time they would always point to like
they try to find some way to protect
liberal decision makers and now it's
coveted but the main number that's up is
shootings and if you take new york city
it's about 97 percent increase are we to
believe
that all of these perps all of a sudden
were let go from their work and then
started shooting people no if you look
it is gang members and that activity and
also what you just mentioned
no cash bail
the prosecutors are lacks basically
they're like we're not going to really
uh prosecute on that law like you can
skate on those types of things and i
believe that the police are starting to
feel like the border patrol does
right they are demeaned and they're
disparaged and so they feel like they
can't do their jobs so they pull back
and what happens when you pull back
everybody comes in yeah jesse same
question here i mean is this deliberate
i mean nine out of ten cities where the
spikes happening are led by
overwhelmingly liberal politicians i
mean it's not a statistical accident
here i'm upset you didn't think i was
the most sober minded analysis uh come
on dan maybe yeah maybe on the scene it
wasn't an intoxication the most
entertaining thank you dana thank you my
father i thought i was quite
sober-minded i just want to my dad who
thinks you are he loves you watching the
show i'm not kidding well thank you very
much doesn't watch my show
that's yours so he watches mine
i know i know let's not let's not
encourage liberals to get together and
talk dana um but the democrats do
nothing wrong dan not in the cities they
run the borders they control
they're perfect people and so sometimes
perfection is misunderstood so a
simple-minded person like myself would
see the democrats empty the prisons to
fund the police bail out the shooters
and looters while at the same time
taking police off the streets and think
wow that would create a spike in
homicides but no no no
it's the china virus dan and that's
actually encouraging it's the one thing
the democrats have blamed on china so
maybe that's a start and if
it is the pandemic that has caused this
spike in homicides
did the spike in homicides occur in all
the other countries in the world well
good thing i checked john rich because i
spent all afternoon looking at murder
rates throughout the world and murder
rates have actually gone down in mexico
colombia russia japan australia flat in
india the united states is the only
country that has seen a historic rise in
2020 in murder maybe it has something to
do with defunding the police i'm not so
sure jess i i come to you last because i
need an explanation for this this can't
possibly be accurate if you believe in
data nine out of ten of those cities are
run by liberals where the spike has
happened and secondly they did research
on this and they determined the
lockdowns happened around the country
and the spike in murders again was only
in areas dominated by liberal
politicians so this is obviously not
true it obviously has something to do
with the politics not kovit
i'm not sure that it has something to do
necessarily with the politics there are
a few things that are important here one
jesse we'll do another segment on that
but all those countries you read they
don't have a rampant gun problem like
the united states of america does check
how many weapons people can still kill
you with the knife go down but they're
not
where people got knifed all the time and
it's still nothing close to our murder
rate so the data that we're talking
about is 2020 those were the trump years
so all of this blaming on president
biden that's happening now actually
under president biden's watch the murder
rate has even gone down another
important component of the fbi data that
the short-term increases was in all
regions not just in those liberal cities
all regions that means in places where
conservatives are that means that this
can all be because of bail reform to
fund the police yada yada yada and also
the murder rate and the crime rate
overall is lower than it was in the
1990s so conservatives are running
around screaming we've never seen
anything like this you have seen
something the fbi was screaming it
wasn't conserving the fbi
i got to see you on the on the trump
point are you seriously suggesting that
when trump during the crime wave after
the george floyd incident there offered
to send in the feds the national guard
to liberal cities to stem the liberal
city crime wave that this was somehow
trump's fault no what i'm suggesting is
that it's hypocritical it's weird like
isn't that weird just let me first my
sentence
no it's not weird because everyone is
talking about this is biden's america
play all the ads this is what's going on
in biden's america this is what happened
in trump's america he oversaw actually
majority of the pandemic because people
have been vaccinated since president
biden was in office so it is important
to point it out because people say it
starts at the top of cities it's i just
also told you from the fbi data it's not
just liberal cities it was all regions
of the top places because there's a
higher concentration of people but there
are regions all over this country like i
said yeah but not run by liberal cities
most of the murders are taking place in
the liberal city just admit i'm right
and then commercial is bad wherever it
happens yes but especially in liberal
cities like nine out of ten or liberal
cities i just want to make sure
everybody got it it's nine out of ten
folks
so just throwing that in there